ah you may remember this topic I've been
employing integration right but really
what it is is um is areas by because
that's what we started in the bubble and
it just so happened that Bremen is
clever idea to even summon limits in
calculus law work that integration is
was a really great way of doing it it's
not just great it's fast its precise and
that's why because it's so good
that's why we keep using it like if
you've got a fast precise method
it makes Sabini have a fast precise
management areas we backwards
what are we probably method actually
methods - I'm not only less accurate but
as you'll discover most of the time it's
usually slower because why would we not
about to spawn it integrates a firewood
ok now two reasons number one we've so
far away you know functions where we
know how to integrate so I start like
this you know we can eat for breakfast
yeah but it's not which we can
differentiate but we integrate suppose I
wanted an area under this curve you know
about this function if you want to later
on I'll teach you how to make
requires fancy on a fancy method fancy
name kind of integration by parts but
the point is like it's hard to work with
okay but we can still work out area yeah
firstly what my function is today
secondly what do you know what the
function is like what if you've got some
measurements ok and what he wants the
area underneath ok but what actually
governs this function don't you know
what it's ok you don't know about that X
to the power of this or whatever you've
just got measurements yes I think that
when did we learn how to deal with
situations like that questions like this
they're like he's a lake we have we have
these measurements work out the area ok
yes ok good question
but the shortage is number one because
you can know it's useful this is why we
cannot let this front pocket cards we're
gonna let see the first one is the
second one is called citizen scientists
okay but doesn't take that much to
realize that you can do better than a
rectangle by using trapeze you okay so
let's just take the simplest case from a
single trapeze if this is the area that
I walked on okay I can make a trip
YouTube that'll be at least in the right
ballpark as this by taking the tops of
birth to function at ease okay okay now
it's important to note that you know
these are vertical so how I go about
lucky calculating sorry the area of this
trapezium what is the the average of the
bases okay sorry of what
and then you take the average of the two
parallel sides okay then - I
deliberately got caught in a Venus or Y
lower bounds okay so that's why I just
watch out sir N+ in you add the vanity
point to gives you the average so this
is standard right now what do each of
these things correspond to if a diagram
where's the perpendicular height of this
trapezium that horizontal in there okay
now in this case it's it's it's more
surprising result that I thought okay
this is me but it's a right now what are
these two parallel sides equals to do
well that's X equal and this is
and the second one is now these are
employment make a note of this it's
introduced in technology the pretty
writer of America's responsibility you
may know these guys after a fee right
because I get these Heights right oh you
know basis if you like by evaluating the
function taking these values and put
them into the function
okay we call them function no okay
the questions will refer to certain
numbers of merchandise so it's important
to know right yeah now that I've got my
pieces what's the area so I can say
number one the area is equal to the
integral from A to B but I'm very sorry
not equal to well now you say that's
approximately equal to this trapezium
that okay so it's this perpendicular
height on the shoe so and then I'm gonna
take the average of the okay so you see
normally we would have said at this
point yeah what's actually equal to if
you know what the previous is then you
evaluate your involve animals but what
is it don't know what the premium is or
I can't be bothered so you can see if
remote reading here don't want
approximate to
now as you can probably imagine this
trapezium that we've just manufactured
might be a good approximation or might
be a lousy approximation right so if I
give you a function let's say I don't
want something like this okay and
suppose I want to find its area for all
them say there's my a up to here to be
right
well the trapezium you make out of this
is five times the size of the area that
I've actually often a trapezoidal rule
highly dependent ballin you know what
kind of fun can you I have pushing it
right but I can still use trapeziums in
a situation like this to get a pretty
good approximation what would I do is
that I would just do the same thing
reven did which is have more of them
okay and so the more trapezium tonight
get pc on the board can change I get the
closer on there
the list is some this era area okay so
how much generalized race over another
graph just like this one and when I know
I'm gonna go from this is kind of basic
trapezoid rule one trapezium to function
values what happens if we have